we went through this whole thing at
Lotte sure era and left at the end of
March and the woman I was with and I
stayed in Colombia another month
everybody else went back and we wrestled
with it another month and I was quite
out of it I think I believed that she
would give birth to the word itself and
I believe that it would be a little
glass fianc bead that I had lost in Laos
five years earlier and when she began to
develop a round sore on the top of her
mouth that was exactly the size of this
thing then I realized that this little
object would drop down onto her tongue
someday soon and she would deliver it to
me and that it would be the Word made
flesh it would be the now are you
alarmed now do you begin to get the
drift that we've attempted to suppress
I was flaming and it's take it took me
years and years to dial it down so that
it's even as friendly and package' Bowl
as it is in the present moment because
for a long time it wasn't I mean it just
drove people to the walls I mean they
just said I don't know and I don't want
to hear anything I've had it and call me
when you're better